One time.
I was talking to a girl and she said she went to Coachella and she had never
done Molly. And she was like,
had her arms up and she was dancing around and the Coachella,
and somebody came up behind her and wiped Molly on her face.
Do it. Hey, let me tell you something. Okay.
If somebody ever did that to me and I've never done Molly,
I've never done drugs. If somebody ever snuck some drugs into me,
I'll tell you right now,
I would fight everyone around me until I was either dead
or high. That's how it will go.
If you wiped Molly in my mouth,
everybody around that person who did that is complicit.
I'm fighting everybody.
I see until I'm dead or tripping.
Cause I know once I'm tripping, I'm not going to want to fight everybody. Right.
I'll be like, I would, that'd be hilarious to be like fighting and. And just,
and just, if you were winning, just beaten the out,
everybody just high kicks and just pop out,
choking people out and doing arm bars and then more people come in,
come on, pap, pap, pap, pap. And then all of a sudden you're just like, ah,
ah. Ah, man. I so good.
The Papa fighting. And then you're wrestling.
But then also it kind of feels good. Cause people are like grabbing on you and.
And you're like, ah, God it. Until all of a sudden it just turns into it.
Well time got me feeling so free. They got Ms.
Santa brain celebrate and dance with me and they were still fighting a little
bit. And you're like bah, but you're like, well, ma time.
And you're just sweating. So Ooh. Yeah. Zana brain
[inaudible] Oh yeah. You're just like, Oh. I've said I'm brain Papa.
I'm all the time is on your back. And you're just like,
you hike them up on your shoulders. And you're like, one more time.
Got me a fan. It's so free,
but you've got somebody on your shoulders and you're having a good time.
But also you're still kind of fighting people.
And then all of a sudden you just let loose and you're just like, you know what?
it. Oh yeah. Tell him I'm Santa brain with me.
And then the beat drops. And you're just like,
[inaudible], you're bloody and exhausted in your shirt's rep. Then
you're just like this place rocks. And you just have a blast for seven hours until all your spinal fluid
has gone. That would be, that would be me. That would be what I did. And then
when, once I came to and all the other guys who were complicit came too
, we'd be like, dude, that rocked. That was one for the ages. But if any of you are ever complicit in putting
Molly
in my face again, we're doing it all over again. And then look at me and they go like this.
Oh yeah, we are dude. And then we ride off into the sunset center. Brian and Dan.
So afraid. And Donna set up,
rang me one month.
Credits, just roll. As we roll off into the sunset
and it's me and the guy from ITTO mama tambien. Like that was like,
he was there, dude,
this is what I see. This is what I'm talking about. When I've talked about the.
I don't need.
I don't want to go do. I don't want to go when people are like,
let's go check it out.
When we're in Ohio or wherever the we are my openers, like we gotta go.
She goes, go see a Rockies game. Whoa, dude.
I don't want to watch guys play baseball when I can just think of like that.
That's so to me to think of a guy getting Malid in his face and
then fighting until he got high and then riding off into the sunset, bro,
what the? I'm going to go watch the Rockies. Play the outta here, dude.